- [Interviewer] All right, Cindy.
- Hi.
- Cindy, where'd grew up?
Where are you from originally?
- [Cindy] I'm from Oklahoma, 700 Valley.
- [Interviewer] Okay and
tell me about your childhood.
You had both of your parents?
- Basically my dad died before I was born,
right before I was born.
Tragic accident at work or something.
So I never met my dad.
My mom raised me and my two brothers
and it was basically okay childhood,
except for the fact that I was touched
by every one of my uncles.
My mom had six brothers
and basically I know now that she traded
molestation acts to me for drugs
and stuff like that
everything came out later on
and I was even kidnapped
by one of my uncles for about two weeks.
And I was pregnant with
his child by 10 years old.
And I couldn't keep the
baby or nothing like that.
- [Interviewer] You got
pregnant at what age?
- Ten.
Yeah, I had just started my
period and I didn't even know
that I was pregnant except that my mom
kept tabs on like getting me pads
and stuff like that and
she took me to the doctor
and I was pregnant.
I didn't even tell her what happened,
but I was in a dark
alley, outside my house
and I was kidnapped by
a man in a dark mask
and raped, brutally raped
and right before I got out of the van,
I took off the mask and it was my uncle.
And basically a couple
other people came forward
and saw it like neighbors and stuff
and they told my mom,
they told the detective.
He ended up going to jail
and I had to press charges
but my mom was really mad at me about it.
So like throughout my whole life,
I didn't really want to tell her anything.
I kept things from her.
'Cause she always made me
feel like it was my fault.
She always-
- [Interviewer] So your
mom was an addict but-
- She was an addict.
- [Interviewer] But she kept the kids.
- Yeah and she works a
good job and stuff at CSUN
and so she always kept a good job
so that's kinda what made me
like always do good in school
like make it look good on the outside
you know what I'm saying?
But really my mom, she was a
really bad addict, really bad.
She had alcohol problem too.
I don't know if it was like
from the loss of my dad, whatever.
Yeah.
- [Interviewer] And when
do you go out on your own?
- I've been on my own
probably since I was 23.
I was addicted to sex and stuff and drugs
and I was just so ashamed
to do that around my family
and of other people to see
me like that, that I knew.
So I came to a different area.
So I came downtown where nobody knew me
and continued to you
sell my body and stuff
and I've had opportunities
to like move forward
and do good and stuff, but I chose it
and I'm not really sure why
but I know that like I'm hungry
for attention and there's a borderline
where like it feels good but it's wrong
and that's attractive to me.
And I think I was just always raised
feeling like it's wrong what is right.
It's wrong what it feels good
and it's like, I still live with that.
- [Interviewer] So what
kind of feelings do you get,
shame and guilt and all that?
- I feel shame and guilt that
I'm not raising my children.
- [Interviewer] How many kids do you have?
- Three boys.
- [Interviewer] Who raises?
- My mom.
- [Interviewer] Your mom.
- And it's sad because I
don't know what's going on,
with them now, with my mom I mean,
I never trusted my mom ever,
but she makes it look so good.
But I talk to my kids like
every other week and stuff
over the phone and Skype and stuff so-
- [Interviewer] Your mom's still using?
- I don't know.
I just, I don't see how she can't.
I know for sure she
uses alcohol every day.
That's her thing, but she
uses her having a good job
and working all day that
she's entitled to drink.
She's entitled to do what she wants,
you know what I'm saying?
As long as she's taking care
of everything financially
and that's kind of like
the role I've taken too.
As long as I take care
of myself financially,
I can do whatever I want.
- [Interviewer] So today you're
living on the street here?
- I'm on the street.
- [Interviewer] You're in
a tent here on Skid Row?
- I'm on a tent and Skid Row
and I have a couple of tents.
I have a boyfriend who's
really controlling,
kind of like a pimp if you wanna call it.
- [Interviewer] So that's
how you're making money?
- Yeah and most of it goes to him
and he doesn't like what I do,
but he gets to spend all of it
and it's just like a revolving
circle of going outside,
getting the money, doing the drugs
and going back outside,
all day, every day.
Now even, I mean, I'm missing work,
but I really wanted to come and do this.
- [Interviewer] And this has got to get
depressing for you, right?
- It's so depressing.
It's very hard.
Every day and to put on a smile
and I mean people know like
if you're going through something,
they don't wanna pick you
up, you know what I'm saying?
So I have to look as good as possible
that's why I'm not your
typical looking prostitute,
you know what I mean?
And I don't dress up all naked or whatever
and the people who know
me, they're loyal to me,
you know what I mean?
And it's more of a conversation
than it is anything,
you know what I'm saying?
Dare able to see like the
real underneath part of me.
- [Interviewer] You have you
regular customers and stuff?
- I have regular people
that have been coming
for five years, every week loyally
and sometimes they don't have
the money, sometimes they do
and if I see them on the
street and I need something,
they'll stop and they'll
give me a couple bucks here
and there or furniture
or anything, blankets.
I'm willing to do anything just to get by.
- [Interviewer] And
what is your drug today?
- Its crack.
- [Interviewer] Crack. How
long have you been using crack?
- It's going on 23 years.
- [Interviewer] So you started early?
- Yeah.
I had an 18 year old boyfriend
and I was like really young at the time
and he got me started on that
and I just been in love
with it ever since.
I just, I stopped, I
stopped for a little bit,
but I always craved to go back.
- [Interviewer] What did crack do for you
when you first started using it?
- It gave me like feeling
sexy and beautiful and mellow,
horny, all feelings,
sexual feelings to me.
- [Interviewer] And what
does it do for you today?
- Same thing.
- [Interviewer] Still works?
- [Interviewer] Okay you're not just-
- Yeah, but more of, it's
more like a chemical balance
to me for like a mood stabilizer today.
I don't get as high on it as I used to,
unless it's really good.
- [Interviewer] It's probably
not as pure as it used to be.
- Right, stomped on, but
it's like, it makes me mad
'cause I keep going to get it.
Keep going to get it no matter
if it's short, it's bad,
it's whatever I'm going.
No matter what I'm going.
I don't know for how long.
- [Interviewer] What is, I mean-
Certainly you're an intelligent woman
and you see that that's gonna
lead nowhere in your life.
- I know.
- [Interviewer] But you
can't break free of it.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] What do you
think people watching this,
just don't understand about addiction?
- I think it has a lot to do with me,
my opinion has a lot to do with
family being there for you,
friends, a good support group,
because I don't have any of that
and I never have and I guess
that's what I'm missing.
- [Interviewer] Did you
ever feel loved as a child?
- Not really, no.
- [Interviewer] No dad?
- No dad.
I just been on a search for
love and trying to fill a hole
that can't be filled.
And I don't know what it is.
I don't know if it's God, I
mean, I have God in my life now.
I don't feel as empty and I
do have my kids that I talk to
so I don't feel as empty,
but I definitely feel
like I'm going nowhere.
I just don't wanna die out here.
Not like this.
- [Interviewer] Have
you been clean before?
- I've been clean,
probably the most for
like three, four years.
I've had a steady job,
but then I always end up going back.
- [Interviewer] What sets you
back? What makes you relapse?
- My relapse, I just like the
urge, even going to meetings
even going to like any meetings
like I feel like using during any meeting,
like I don't know, like talking about it,
not talking about it you know.
- [Interviewer] Is it
like a constant battle
just to not use, even when you're clean?
- Yeah.
'Cause like, I feel good when I'm clean.
I like myself better, but I
can't wait to do it again.
It's like that constant
like I know it's wrong,
but it feels good.
It's like a never ending story in my life.
Is it wrong because it feels good?
I grew up with that feeling.
Even in my sex life with my boyfriend
I can't be with him unless we're doing
some kind of role play based
on my childhood trauma.
I'm constantly asking him
to pretend he's my uncle
or my dad or some kind of family member.
It's embarrassing to say, but
that's the truth, literally.
I think he feels bad.
- [Interviewer] And working
here, picking up guys
on Skid Row that's dangerous sometimes.
- [Cindy] Yeah.
- [Interviewer] What kind of stuff is?
- [Cindy] I've been stabbed.
I've been kicked out of cars, beat up,
drugged, you know what I'm saying?
Just people have stolen my money.
Made me do the do and then taking my money
and I've even walked home
with no shoes, no clothes,
after doing a whole night of job
and it's the worst feeling.
I'm mad at myself, I'm mad at myself.
I won't go do this with
somebody I don't know this time,
but when I'm desperate,
it's like I have no choice.
Whatever comes up, you know?
- [Interviewer] Do you have any friends?
- [Cindy] I really don't.
I think I get to say I have one friend
and I don't know how loyal that person is.
- [Interviewer] What do
you think might help you
get out of this situation?
- [Cindy] Myself. Just to, I don't know.
I mean God and me, I don't know.
I'd like to say, oh if I had a
really good job that came up,
or if I moved, but I think
no matter where I would go
I would search out my drug.
Or I end up working somehow I don't know.
- [Interviewer] Do you think
there's something about this,
this life that just is
addictive, is attractive?
- Yeah.
Not just the drug its everything.
- [Interviewer] Yeah you
feel like you belong here.
- Everything. Yeah.
- [Interviewer] In this
situation, this life.
- It's so weird 'cause I
know I'm not from here,
but I never felt like I
belonged so much in my life.
- [Interviewer] Whereas if you were living
in a beautiful house somewhere,
in a nice neighborhood,
beautiful car and family
and everything.
- Exactly.
I come from money and
now I'm working for it.
- [Interviewer] Do you probably-
- I didn't need for
anything. I Had my own car.
- [Interviewer] Yeah,
but if you have that now
you'd probably sabotage it right?
- Right.
And it's almost like I'm
like I'm punishing myself
or something and not
even because I deserve it
because my mom always told
me that I deserved it.
She always made me feel
like everything I did,
I acted on, I brought it
on, it was called for,
you know what I'm saying?
And somewhere deep down I
think maybe it happened to her.
Maybe it's normal for her.
It was like a repetition thing.
- [Interviewer] Yeah it's almost
like the generational curse
continues on-
- Exactly.
- [Interviewer] and our kids are-
- And everybody knows it.
Everybody knows it, but
nobody talks about it.
- [Interviewer] But now
your kids are living
with their grandmother.
- Yeah, I just don't know what's going on
and I don't want to
sabotage them with DCFS
so it's like, until I hear otherwise
I'm just going along with it.
I don't really have any
control over it anyway like,
I just eventually wanna
be somebody that my kids
can look up to or say
that she was this bad,
but she made it out.
And I take responsibility
for the way I'm living now,
you know what I'm saying?
I know that I could do better
and I should do better.
I wanna do better.
I don't know what the first step is.
- [Interviewer] What's
the most important lesson
you've learned?
- That everybody has
problems in their life.
Nobody is perfect, you know what saying?
Nobody is better than anybody else,
but we all need each other in some way.
Everybody needs somebody and not to judge
because we don't wanna be judged.
I don't wanna be judged,
you know what I'm saying?
And I think that I've learned
out here to be a better person
to humans in general and not
to look down upon other people
in a worse position than I am or a better,
because I've been in both
sides, you know what I'm saying?
I just wanna be happy.
I just want to love people
and I think like how they
say love conquers all.
I think if we all just got along better
and helped each other more,
that we'll all be okay
and I found a piece of
God and I want more.
It might be my way out.
- [Interviewer] All right, Cindy.
Well thank you so much
for talking with me.
- Thank you.
- [Interviewer] And good luck
with your life from here.
- Thank you very much.
- [Interviewer] Thank you.
- Thanks.